Reco good mood is that a song it is a
song New York soul singer producer soul
is in Korea
up learning about new music I just
listened to what's on the radio Pikachu
Funko Pop is that personal music is this
music
45. is that all right is that another
artist sake oh
oh he has very particular taste
difference between pan pizza and hand
tossed Pizza wait so he cooks green flag
green flag yeah Maru okay
a K-Town regular I see I work there oh
what is that dude it's an anime okay so
you don't watch anime I don't watch
anime but I don't think I I
TFT syndra re-roll
okay I have nothing in common
yeah you have you really don't you have
nothing in common I have nothing in
common